hello
and welcome to playstation grenade it's
now week 12 of fortnite season 5
chapter 2 only 27 days until the season
ends
this week's update is not as monumental
as you may expect so i'm going to add a
few
behind the scenes updates too so if you
sit your butt down for five minutes and
kindly think about using code adamaru in
the store
let's break down the new update
okay so if you are only here for
physical map updates
then i can tell you that no pois have
changed
the bunker remains closed lazy lakes
insurance office
still hasn't been completed hut watch
version 2 remains in one piece
but that flatbed truck is hovering
mighty close above it
maybe one day it will knock her down
again the only map
change i can see are these llamas or
rather
the wacky waving inflatable arm flailing
tube llamas
wacky waving inflatable arm flailing too
man these chaps can be found at almost
all gas stations and petrol stations on
the island
and we can pretty much guess they are
going to be used for a challenge
and that's it no other changes i can
spot but if you see any
hit me up on twitter please but there
are other things i think we should look
at
we don't usually talk about loading
screens in map updates well not since
chapter 1
but look at this the new foxclan reborn
screen
has been uncovered and depicts the three
fox members parkouring around
what looks to be lucky landing but on
closer inspection
this is far far bigger than the original
lucky landing
if you've seen my foxclan video i
surmised what i think's happening and
linked this
to the hunter condor and his clues about
cherry blossom
ultimately many of us thought that lucky
landing was returning
but now two updates later still nothing
happening here
with only 27 days of the season
remaining this loading screen
may be our first official look at season
six and the core storyline around the
fox clan
and drift i was kind of thinking this
lady's name vi
could be a nod at six the roman numerals
telling us next season is about the
foxclan
so i ran a poll on twitter and then
fortnite said they liked my cut
threw me a bit of shade and ran their
own poll most people say she's called v
so i will call her v from now on
[Music]
since we last met i'm sure you've seen
the valentine missions including
leviathan
and of course another set of hunters
johnsy has been recruiting
arrived on the island in the form of
tron legacy
these cracks in time will continue
appear as jonesy keeps on bringing
hunters here
two more tentacles will leech off the
zero point in the next week or so
link two space bananas and bandages who
do you think the final hunters will be
samus from metroid
maybe lara croft who is currently
celebrating 25 years in gaming
what about overwatch if you have a
different theory to these three please
throw them in the comments and flex
when you get it right the zero point
itself looks quite stable
still but with all this extra effort of
rifting different areas and times
things don't look too cracking for this
big sphere in the sky
will it explode like it did in season x
how often do you spend time in party
royale i personally
forgot it existed but later this week
there is a showcase here for you to
watch
fortnite presents short night on
february 20th
and 21st the big screen in party royale
will be used to showcase
short form content we don't know much
about it yet
but this is round about the same time in
chapter 1 where fortnite shops began
popping up
especially on youtube remember jonesy
getting on a bus full of tomatoes
or what about the fabled story which
told us how peely
was made
[Music]
damn it even peely is a jaunty skin on
february 20th we may
see the expanded law grow and i do hope
so
okay so back to map updates for the last
12 weeks you guys have been
flexing on me in my twitter dms about
all the easter eggs you keep finding in
those io elevators
well today i finally got one myself and
it's the best one of all
i finally met bill and ted after opening
around
500 iopods it happened you beautiful
boogers
the bromance lives on out of interest
have you seen these guys in game yet
and be honest am i the last one to find
them i feel like we need a montage
of good times right now
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
a spot many of you guys want me to look
at in more detail is flush factory
back in chapter one this was the spot
noobs like me landed to get easy wins to
inflate our stats
now in chapter 2 it returned and it
doesn't get much love
inside everything is identical from
chapter one the spray paint room the
toilet conveyor belt
and the thing that most people don't
notice the lobby here is a crazy amount
of detail for a fortnight poi
back in the day the floating toilets of
the future meant nothing to us
but little did we know these were
foreshadowing season nine
and bunker jonesy coming out in the
future another great touch
are these toilet seats of employees of
the month on the wall
i think i'm writing saying that these
guys are from save the world and
are survivors that we can rescue there
the only one i know for certain is this
one because it's your mum
yes we came back to this poi just so i
could tell a terrible joke
i hope it was worth it but to be honest
this spot like many others on the map
directly lines up with that of all gpois
in chapter one
the viking ship the restaurants dusty
containers
and now flush factory i'm thinking these
are all clues towards the new season
right now i'm currently working on a
video about what to expect from the live
event
and things we hope to see in season 6.
if you have any ideas or theories about
the new season
please reply in the comments below and
i'll be sure to read as many as i can
what will happen in the live event and
season six if you have some good
theories i'll make another video
this week
okay so there we have it fortnite update
time has been and gone
and the live event is fast approaching
on screen now are more legends who rock
code adamaru and let me class what i do
as a job thank you very much for
sticking with me i really appreciate it
i'm hoping to make more fortnite content
over the next month so if you don't see
your name right now
keep the faith more videos and more
thank yous are incoming
i'm adam from playstation grenade you're
awesome if you're still here right now
take a digital high five
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you